oh we've got a few high clouds in the
sky really pretty and that's just kind
of a ribbon of clouds out there as we
look off to the west over the spring
mountains those clouds will be exiting
soon they'll be leaving us and that's
going to give us a great sunny day
doggone this number didn't change 54
degrees in aleonte 40s across the south
valley here i'm just going to
quickly change this number right here 45
up now up at nellis 48 in henderson this
morning 42 out at red rock and 40 up at
kyle canyon this morning not much in the
way of wind at all the latest drought
monitor at the end of november now it's
showing us extreme to exceptional
drought for areas of central and
southern nevada this is all of the
western states right now arizona
improved because of such a great monsoon
season over the winter so that really
pulled them out of drought most drought
status not all but most and then right
here in clark county you can see we're
still extreme to exceptional but really
central nevada needs some rain badly so
does southern and central california and
then even parts of oregon you know with
those terrible wildfires up there over
the summertime and montana needs a lot
of rain and snow so here's what we're
getting today a high of 71 degrees when
our normal high for december 3rd is 59.
the sunrise was 6 35 and sunset at 4 26
record high 77 remember just a couple of
days ago we had a record high of 75 very
first day of the month storm track
staying way up north there's more rain
and snow for the northwest look at the
snow coming in from canada right through
the upper midwest the great lakes
skipping over to the northeast there'll
be record highs across the central and
southern plains today in the 70s and 80s
desert southwest not much to see a
little bit of activity on the satellite
picture and that's because those high
clouds are moving through and they're
sliding north away from us here in las
vegas so we'll have good sunshine 71
degrees low 70's through the weekend
look how mild next week we start sliding
down into the 60s with a few systems
that move into the west breezy winds one
of those at the end of the week could
bring us a slight chance of showers and
look at those much cooler 50s so heavier
jackets probably a good idea by next
weekend